you
67 was that number and Lucas got it so
we have well still to be determined
opening wish heading for King's Indian
will d5 be played or not it's the big
question d5 or Bishop g7 which road will
we go down Kings Indian defense or still
grünfeld land if Bishop here well I
could be responding d4 it's either one
of those moves
yeah I might go for if d5 I might go for
d4 bishop yeah d4 Queen b3 putting more
pressure on this alright let's go with
that
grünfeld it is takes Knight takes e4
Knight takes pawn takes and the idea
will be to break down the center but we
don't have that so black gives up their
center and now I can freely place us an
additional pawn in the center this
Knight now runs the risk of getting
kicked around and if I'm able to recoup
this pawn with Bishop take C then that
just turns out to be a waste of time
so Black has given up the center and I'm
able to develop and recapture so what
does black have in store right now is
this something that should worry me I
don't think so
here's one quick tactic to be aware of
Bishop g7 I take the pawn Bishop g4
would be a blunder because of bishop
takes f7 King takes followed by 95 and
we could soon be seeing this actually
hang on though Bishop takes Knight
I can't recapture with the Queen at that
point but I'm okay with that I'll take
with the pawn reinforce my center and
then eventually play here so Bishop g7
is a blunder if it's played and
hopefully my opponent is not listening
to the stream keep in mind these are
eventually uploaded to youtube streaming
live right now on twitch and this tactic
isn't available Bishop takes King takes
Knight here there would be Knight takes
Knight hmm but is there something else
there's pressure on d4 twice I'm
defending it twice but I can't rely upon
him as a defender so Bishop e3 is one of
my first thoughts but I if you have two
pawns in the center you might as well
try and flex their muscles here
can they do something better can they
enter blacks territory with tempo both
of them do just that but is it a good
idea pawn push where does this night go
to actually pawn push seems good come to
think of it because the only thing
that's preventing me from this tactic is
this Knight defending the bishop for
example a5 if this Knight runs away and
I have bishop takes King takes the
knight here and the Queen takes at the
end of it though I'm losing d4 pawn push
knight here two pieces are hit bishop at
night I probably have to drop back it
still might not be a bad thing to do I
feel like I'd be able to have some type
of a pawn storm if I go forward that
variation it seems like there's some
winning continuation here because
there's so many four interesting like
forceful continuations that's the better
word forceful continuations tempo
gaining those d5 e5 which one is better
let me try this one again e5 Knight runs
away actually e5 Bishop takes to be
played first I think I'm gonna go with
this one
yeah let's go with this if Knight here
I'm not afraid of that actually I'm
gonna drop back and I'll I'm retreating
but I'm I'm actually attacking when I'm
retreating because I'd be threatening on
e5 so 95 Bishop e2 I'm still throwing
some punches at black with my moves d5
to start a knight here Bishop back or
there's Bishop takes first Queen takes
and then Knight here Queen back to e2
Knight takes Bishop Queen takes I stand
well in that position I think because I
still maintain a space advantage in the
center I have a
good presence in the center let's drop
back a good presence in the center and
I'm not I've accomplished that by not
wasting any time there was an earlier
waste of time on the black side with D
take C and I'm able to push forward with
d5 gain space with tempo on the knight
on c6 so what to do about this tension
one minute 35 for black okay they
captured and this is what I had been
planning to do I'm gonna ruin my pawn
structure so that I could continue
making progress in the center with these
advances so I'm grabbing some more space
this Knight has to find a new home and
if he plays here I could do this and hit
him again although often I have to be a
little bit cautious of f5 maybe I'm
keeping the night away to ask where he
wants to go to I bet you I bet you this
nights going to go here on his own but
then where does the bishop go I'm going
to shift gears a little bit
I'm going I'm gonna come out and hit
this weak point on b7 and then look into
this mouth here now if Bishop g7 black
runs into trouble now with f4 defense of
e5 and an attack on the night and he
wouldn't have g7 available one-minute
warning for black one thing to question
your own games is like that move right
there
I did think about f4 attacking the
knight but then I thought to myself
might I just be attacking a piece
chasing a piece away 2 squared I already
wanted to go to and I think he would
like to go to g7 and then f5 what's
stopping me from just taking this pawn
or is there something better I could
play this I'm not seeing anything wrong
with taking this pawn though maybe my
opponent was banking on me taking on c6
and then the recapture at the bishop but
this threat on b7 hasn't been met I am
looking into e6 though
see six takes takes Bishop has to go
back home this pond seems like it might
drop off with Queen d6 to e6 stuff I'm
just gonna grab a pond I don't see
anything wrong with that
and I'm gonna recapture it to my clean
putting it opposite there's and if this
bishop gets too crazy Bishop b5 check is
going to end the game very quick okay we
don't have that keep my queen central it
seems like a good home same story again
Bishop here F for less than 30 seconds
for black I guess this is being prepped
but I can meet Bishop c6 with Bishop
here or can I now that would be a
blunder Bishop c6 Bishop here Bishop
takes Knight takes Queen a5 check and
after I drop back with my knight there
beer up takes a knight recapture Queen
takes c3 I drop my rook but I have time
right now to Castle and get out of that
pin so let's do just that
there is some weaknesses over here near
my king but black is in no position to
exploit that I'm not sure it matters
which rope I put on the defy let's just
go at this one stops castling and I'm
gonna take with this pawn watch over my
dark squares although it's at this point
it's not going to matter its advanced
I'm hitting the knight now and I can
look into at this point just doubling on
the D file but we didn't get there let's
go back good game let's go back flip how
to make an improvement right here don't
take on this c4 square finish your
development Bishop g7 when I take then
you recapture and when I advanced with
e4 you take the knight in your idea at
that point understanding the theme in
this opening will be to strike at d4 you
have your Bishop on g7 pointing here you
strike at it with your bishop you strike
at it with your pawn you strike at it
with your knight Bishop g7 c5 knight c6
you get castled there's maybe
possibilities to undermine my control
over the d4 square with Bishop g4
eliminating a defender of that square
that's the direction to go and capturing
this turns out to be waste of time
because I pick him up I pick this c4
pawn up without any loss of time I
develop and recapture that's my main
point right here because it's already
quite critical I have this mobile upon
mass in the center and there just seems
like there has to be a good variation a
good continuation for me at this point
and it comes all the way back to the
time wasted of capturing here and giving
up the center that's the biggest thing
that I could really add from this game
here
you